Write your own training loop in PyTorch.
In this video, we will look at how we can
do the same fine-tuning as in the Trainer
video, but without relying on that class.
This way you will be able to easily customize
each step of the training loop to your needs.
This is also very useful to manually debug
something that went wrong with the Trainer
API.
Before we dive into the code, here is a sketch
of a training loop: we take a batch of training
data and feed it to the model.
With the labels, we can then compute a loss.
That number is not useful on its own, but
is used to compute the gradients of our model
weights, that is the derivative of the loss
with respect to each model weight.
Those gradients are then used by the optimizer
to update the model weights and make them
a little bit better.
We then repeat the process with a new batch
of training data.
If any of this is unclear, don't hesitate
to take a refresher on your favorite deep
learning course.
We will use the GLUE MRPC dataset here again,
and we have seen how to preprocess the data
using the Datasets library with dynamic padding.
Checkout the videos linked below if you haven't
seen them already.
With this done, we only have to define PyTorch
DataLoaders, which will be responsible to
convert the elements of our dataset into batches.
We use our DataCollatorForPadding as the collate
function, and shuffle the training set.
To check that everything works as intended,
we try to grab a batch of data and inspect
it.
Like our dataset elements, it's a dictionary,
but this time the values are not a single
list of integers, but a tensor of shape batch
size by sequence length.
The next step is to send the training data
in our model.
For that, we will need to create our model.
As seen in the model API video, we use the
from_pretrained method and adjust the number
of labels to the number of classes we have
on this dataset, here two.
Again, to be sure everything is going well,
we pass the batch we grabbed to our model
and check there is no error.
If the labels are provided, the models of
the Transformers library always return the
loss directly.
We will be able to do loss.backward() to compute
all the gradients, and will then need an optimizer
to do the training step.
We use the AdamW optimizer here, which is
a variant of Adam with proper weight decay,
but you can pick any PyTorch optimizer you
like.
Using the previous loss and computing the
gradients with loss.backward(), we check that
we can do the optimizer step without any error.
Don't forget to zero your gradient afterward,
or at the next step they will get added to
the gradients you compute!
We could already write our training loop,
but we will add two more things to make it
as good as it can be.
The first one is a learning rate scheduler,
to progressively decay our learning rate to
zero.
The get_scheduler function from the Transformers
library is just a convenience function to
easily build such a scheduler, you can again
use any PyTorch learning rate scheduler instead.
Finally, if we want our training to take a
couple of minutes instead of a few hours,
we will need to use a GPU.
The first step is to get one, for instance
by using a colab notebook.
Then you need to actually send your model
and training data on it by using a torch device.
Double-check the following lines print a CUDA
device for you!
We can now put everything together!
First we put our model in training mode (which
will activate the training behavior for some
layers like Dropout) then go through the number
of epochs we picked and all the data in our
training dataloader.
Then we go through all the steps we have seen
already: send the data to the GPU, compute
the model outputs, and in particular the loss.
Use the loss to compute gradients, then make
a training step with the optimizer.
Update the learning rate in our scheduler
for the next iteration and zero the gradients
of the optimizer.
Once this is finished, we can evaluate our
model very easily with a metric from the Datasets
library.
First we put our model in evaluation mode,
then go through all the data in the evaluation
data loader.
As we have seen in the Trainer video, the
model outputs logits and we need to apply
the argmax function to convert them into predictions.
The metric object then has an add_batch method
we can use to send it those intermediate predictions.
Once the evaluation loop is finished, we just
have to call the compute method to get our
final results!
Congratulations, you have now fine-tuned a
model all by yourself!